let's take a look at the latest uh
between Chris Christie and the failed
twice indicted twice impeached former
president Donald Trump as you may
remember Donald Trump attacked Chris
Christie for his way listen Chris
Christie is obese there's no question
about it but as I said at the time uh
several weeks ago Donald Trump is also
obese and one of the real signs of
occult leader as is Donald Trump is that
a cult leader can criticize others for
things that they themselves could be
criticized for and their followers don't
care about the double standard they
don't care about the person in a glass
house throwing stones or the pot calling
the kettle black or whatever phrase you
want to use here is Chris Christie
asked on Fox about the fact that Trump
goes after him for his weight and Chris
Christie points out Trump's fat Trump's
also fat once Trump started hitting back
at you on a number of fronts he took aim
at your weight what was your reaction to
that oh well like he Summit honest
um I mean please uh you know look
Howie there are tens of millions of
Americans out in your audience watching
right now who like me have struggled
with their weight true I continue to
struggle I continue to try to do better
um and so do they and what's that got to
do with my competence for office I ran
the governorship of New Jersey for eight
years I think in a very energetic
successful way responded to Hurricane
Sandy working 20 hours a day for weeks I
don't know what his point is you know
what it is it's like a child it's a
bully on the schoolyard who teases you
and makes fun of you but here's my
message to him I don't care what he says
about me and I don't care what he thinks
about me and he should take a look in
the mirror every once in a while maybe
he dropped the weight thing off of his
list of criticisms yeah so Chris
Christie is completely correct of course
you might remember that at one point
Donald Trump published this totally
corrosive uh truth to truth Central
where Trump said quote how many times
did Chris Christie use the words small
does he have a psychological problem
with size actually his speech was small
and not very good okay he goes on he
also posted this photoshopped meme
from Chris Christie's Oak campaign
opener Town Hall where it looks like
Christy is at a buffet of some kind
holding like a massive plate of food and
yeah there's a million other examples of
this uh Trump's obese okay remember that
Trump claimed with the help of Dr Ronnie
Jackson to weigh 239 and be six foot
three inches tall we know that Trump is
not six feet three inches tall uh when
you see him standing next to a Tom Brady
for example or you see him standing next
to Barack Obama Obama you realize that
Trump is very much not six three
um just being shorter than six three
alone would make him obese also nobody
believes he weighs 239 somewhere in the
26270 range seems to make a lot more
sense so Trump is obese but the point
here is
this is what cult leaders get away with
the cult followers allow you to
criticize others for things that are
also characteristics about you
Chris Christie is right to point out to
the Fox News audience Trump is also fat
now sure Chris Christie is more visibly
obese than Trump there's no doubt about
it but the point I think would be best
made here is to turn this into a losing
argument instead of saying anything else
say okay yeah I'm overweight so is Trump
so are tens of millions of Americans is
this really the issue that we have
facing us now we'll talk about how Chris
Christie's polling has improved and it
has improved but is it really going
anywhere viable we don't really know the
answer to that
um we'll see what the reaction is to
this latest commentary from Chris
Christie but Chris Christie is Right
Trump's obese think of your most
personal emails if you're using a free
email provider you should know that
they're scanning every email you send
and receive even after you delete it
they're usually using the data to build
a picture of your life to show you ads
which many find creepy our sponsor start
mail never scans or tracks your emails
privacy is what comes first and unlike
other email Services when you delete an
email in start mail it is gone forever
it also protects your data by blocking
tracking pixels and emails which
companies and hackers can use to track
you you can create unlimited email
aliases to protect your identity and cut
down on spam you can encrypt every email
you send even if the recipient isn't
using encryption start mail gives you 20
gigs of storage that's more than you get
on Gmail and it only takes a few clicks
to migrate all of your emails and
contacts over to start mail go to
startmail.com Pacman to get 50 off your
first year that's only about two bucks a
month the link is down below